The Flash is changing everything for the
DC Cinematic Universe but what exactly
happens next here's where things stand
for the series now that the credits have
rolled warning Major Spoilers ahead for
The Flash no extra tragedy to find you
no matter how many cameos and bat folks
The Flash features it's ultimately a
movie about two things Barry Allen's
personal development and the butterfly
effect of time travel while exploring
these things the film introduces a whole
lot of new Concepts as well as a number
of intriguing alternate universe
characters some of whom are extremely
familiar the movie's climax more or less
confirms that every major DC adjacent
project from the Tim Burton Superman
movie that never existed to the 1960s
Batman show takes place in some
alternate universe in fact the bulk of
The Flash seems to take place in the
Burton Batman Universe where Michael
Keaton's Batman is the only high-profile
costumed hero then again the flash is
also the second to last movie in the DC
extended Universe which is set to give
way to the new James Gunn and Peter
saffron DCU after Aquaman and the lost
kingdom so what exactly is its impact on
the DC movie universe's future is George
Clooney the main Batman again what does
Aquaman do when he wakes up in the
puddle Barry leaves him in in the
post-credits scene will the flash
himself appear in more movies or have we
seen the last of him Huey these quests
questions have concrete answers yet but
based on what we know about the
franchise's future here's what seems
most likely the big thing that
determines much of the Flash's impact on
the DC movie universe is whether the
movie is considered a part of the DCU
right now it doesn't appear to be of the
four DC movies that were in production
when Gunn became the DC Studios
co-president the only one he's confirmed
to be in the DCU is Blue Beetle the
filmmaker shared as much in an
appearance on inside of you with Michael
Rosenbaum first DCU character for sure
is Blue Beetle in the First full DC DCU
movie is Superman
going by this logic this would make the
Flash and elseworld story that
effectively takes place in its own
bubble Universe much like the ones we
see in its climax the events of the
movie certainly happen they're just not
part of the mainline DCU and therefore
wacky things like George Clooney
returning as Bruce Wayne can take place
of course all of this can change in a
moment's notice Gunn could fire up his
Twitter tomorrow and announce that the
flash is a DCU movie which would mean
that it's Multiverse Concepts time
traveling Antics and Clooney Bruce
Wayne's are all legitimate parts of the
mainline story at least until Barry
takes another jog into the Chrono Bowl
as for the flash himself the character
is such a key DC hero that it would be
frankly shocking if a version of him
wouldn't make an appearance in the DCU
at some point down the line it remains
to be seen whether the flash will get a
sequel and if the controversy riddled
Miller will be recast if it happens but
Barry Allen could still have a future in
the DCU if the flash performs at the box
office after all Gunn has said that
while the movie is something of a reset
it is by no means a hard reset gun
previously shared on social media flash
resets many things not all things some
characters remain the same some do not
The Flash is an ideas movie and the
reset gun mentions is quite likely the
introduction of the Multiverse not so
much the alternate universe's concept
itself but the opportunity it provides
to mix and match characters The Flash
has plenty of fun doing this and it
proves that the concept can work pretty
well by teaming Tim Burton era Batman
with two different Barry Allen's and
franchise newcomer Karas or L and
putting them against Man of Steel
villain General Zod the movie employs a
fun smashing different action figures
together strategy that seems like a
great fit for gun the introduction of
this concept may be the Flash's True
Legacy in the long run as it acts as the
precedent that gives the DCU free reign
to use old and new characters as they
see fit combined with the elseworlds
concept this means that the DCU can Now
operate however it likes really which is
probably just how gun and saffron like
it if they want to roll with Jason
momoa's Aquaman going forward they can
totally keep him and bring him in the
next Justice League with whoever ends up
playing the new Mainline versions of
Superman Batman Wonder Woman and so
forth on the other hand they want to
oust an actor the Flash's endless amount
of alternate universes and changing
Futures have given the DCU a perfect
tool kit to replace the characters with
new versions which come to think of it
is pretty much what the movie does to
Ben Affleck's Batman it's hard to
believe that the DCU wouldn't establish
a Mainline Universe because it'll
probably need a through line for longer
arcs and people will likely want to know
what the main versions of characters are
to truly care about them still even with
this very minor limitation it's easy to
see why gun has praised The Flash after
all the movie has given his DCU The
Ultimate Gift near total creative
freedom
foreign
[Music]